the Philadelphia Eagles have a new
quarterback darius slay or worst kept
secret the guy wants to be traded and
the Eagles got in think about this the
Eagles once got Golden Tate for half of
a year for a third-round pick
they got darius slay for a three and a
five and a three-year extension and he's
getting paid and it's easy to pay and we
don't have to give up much to get him
darius slay addressing one of the
biggest areas of need one of the biggest
liabilities on the Eagles roster that
secondary huge move for the Eagles yeah
huge move I mean really as Darius slay
you know and without a doubt one of the
you know you could argue is one of the
five best corners in football he's
certainly in the top ten Jim Schwartz
the D coordinator drafted Darius lay so
I'm not shocked to see this you know Jim
Schwartz does play a lot of man-to-man
Darius slay he can live on an island and
this has been a weakness of their
football team the last few years so you
know they're building some depth in that
secondary you know I think with you know
another loss Malcolm Jenkins but
resigned Jalen Mills they still got
Sydney Jones he's another year out from
tearing his Achilles injury I think he
can be a better player as well but they
needed this type of marquee wide
receiver for Jim Schwartz who can be
creative and he is the type of guy that
could go hey Darius let you play
man-to-man on Amari Cooper and I'm gonna
do all these other different things over
here to help out stop the Cowboys run
game or stop at Michael got whatever it
may be this will give him a little
creativity that way much needed move big
time too big moves that I think I've
flown under the radar I mean that was
great but Darius slay and then getting
Javon Hargrave from the Pittsburgh
Steelers Mike those are two things I
just looked at like Hargrave not a
superstar but one of the best you know
run stoppers in football to have him
next to Fletcher Cox now and now you
have a Malik Jackson coming back from
injury man they're gonna have some
versatility and some size there along
with some some better secondary play in
Philadelphia and I wouldn't be surprised
and I'd have to look at Malik Jackson's
contract and see what guarantees are
left or whatnot but I wouldn't be
surprised if Malik Jackson ends up off
the roster yeah you know when you make a
move like that to bring in Hargrave it's
got the deals got 17 million guaranteed
you know 4.6 million of his
this year is guaranteed it wouldn't
surprise me if they try to trade him but
they are on the hook for 4.6 million of
his salary this season and I'm looking
at this and it's quite possible I don't
know I got to do a little more research
it may be that they've restructured it
looks like they they did restructure so
he's gonna he's gonna still be on the
team as a bonus
they've already yeah it looks like
they've restructured Malik Jackson so
he'll be there but you know they when
when they won the Super Bowl what did
they have that's right and of eight guys
that they constantly brought him in
flipped him in kept him fresh and they
overwhelm an offensive line yeah that
that's the key to their football team it
was one of the greatest strengths and
they did they lost that the last two
years I mean they lost some players in
free agency you know Chris long retired
Brandon Graham is not as dominant as he
was you know their first-round pick the
the pass rusher out of Tennessee I'm
blanking on his name he's had a few
injuries you know so yeah they need they
need this you know this is they need to
be dominant up front they haven't had
that aspect of their football team and
this this will be a big improvement for
them if they can stay healthy and with
these additions Dirk Barnett right Derek
Barnett there it is thank you very much
the guy who they tried to block with a
tight end yeah Wow the NFC Championship
game was still in the balance 14-7 the
Eagles led the Vikings were driving Case
Keenum rolled to the right David Morgan
coming in motion to block Derek Barnett
didn't work Barnett blasted through him
hit Keenan from behind
fumble three plays later touchdown
Eagles game over but but on the top but
I'll have chalk torn it worked because
he just drew a line and he said you
block him and they said damn okay we're
good we don't have we don't have to
worry about the human aspect of this
we're good I drew a line I crossed it
he's blocked him we're good you're right
Mike it's the some of the dumbest [ __ ] I
see weekly in the NFL sorry for swearing
but when I see tight ends blocking
Khalil Mac or cop to your pass rushers I
just want to go I hope your quarterback
gets sacked and you fumble I hope it
happens you know that's the that that
kind of crap doesn't happen you don't
see New England do that you don't see
the better offenses in football do that
very often that's for sure
but here's the thing Chris and this is
what astounds me if a couple of
knuckleheads like us know it how in the
hell are they still doing it I know Mike
because it is very hard to reorganize
your whole pass rush blocking scheme for
an offensive line to make sure you get
your five offensive linemen on you know
the four best rushers it's not always
easy and it's just a cop-out to go hey
tight end you got here you know it takes
a lot of work that's why Dante scarred
Nekia is one of the greatest old line
coaches in the history of football
because he figures out to go hey I don't
care if I got Gronkowski or whatever
he's not gonna block this one of the
better pass rushers in football that's
not his cup of tea and he'll find ways
to make sure and he'll teach Brady and
everybody hey pointed this linebacker
and therefore we can get a tackle on
that pass rusher and then maybe we can
get Gronkowski to block a linebacker or
a safety that fits it better but really
that's what it is it's very hard to make
sure you got the old linemen on the pass
rusher and it's just a cop-out or a
little bit of laziness by coaches more
times than not Mike and we're not
talking about a chip right no or a
double-team we're talking about
situations where they draw it up for a
tight end to be blocking a pass rusher
it is idiotic unless the tight end
weighs 350 pounds right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports